if friends had a seventh friend or a
character most familiar to even casual
viewers it was Gunther the manager of
the gang's coffee shop hangout he was
often seen flitting around in the
background at Central Park on the
occasion that Gunther spoke in one of
his more than 150 appearances it was to
quietly and for lonely Express his
unrequited love for former coworker
Rachel or to deliver a blistering Barb
against the on again off again boyfriend
of Ross how's your birthday May 5th why
oh I I I'm just making a list of
people's birthdays oh mine's December
yeah whatever he appeared on the long
awaited long delayed Friends reunion
special in 2021 but via Zoom because of
health concerns Tyler told today that he
had been diagnosed with Advanced
prostate cancer in 2018 and the disease
had spread to his bones in October 2021
the 59-year-old actor died Jennifer
Aniston who played Rachel wrote in an
Instagram post friends would not have
been the same without you thank you for
the laughter you brought to the show and
to all of our Lives you will be so
missed